Look! Up on the screen! It's a bird! It's a plane!
It's … It's Superman… Lives? Where
did this fight scene come from?
Warning: spoilers ahead!
With his long-awaited DC comics blockbuster
"The Flash" finally racing across the finish
line into theaters across the country, director
Andy Muschietti has given Superman fans one of
the most shocking surprises ever — at least it
would've been shocking if he hadn't spoiled it
weeks ahead of the film's release. Yes, we're
talking about that jaw-dropping, head-scratching
"cameo" appearance from none other than
"Nicolas Cage" in the role of the Man of Steel.
Much hay was made of his inclusion
in the film after Muschietti leaked
the news. While both the scene and the
uproarious reaction from fans may have
been confusing for casual observers,
it's actually a reference to an almost
mythological DC comics project that
was shelved many, many years ago.
Having existed only through vague recollections
and test footage, fans familiar with the project
have likely been in the clouds themselves
imagining what it might look like when
they finally get a glimpse at the "Superman"
film that might've been. Then again, now that
they've actually had a chance to see the scene for
themselves in the context of the uneven multiverse
story of "The Flash," they may now be questioning
if it's worth all the hay in Smallville.
For those experiencing the legend of Nicolas
Cage's Superman for the first time in "The
Flash," we'll briefly recap its long, confusing
history in development hell. The story goes that,
hot off the success of his indie film "Clerks,"
Kevin Smith was contacted by Warner Bros. to write
a new "Superman" film within the universe of Tim
Burton's "Batman" series. Later in the process,
Burton himself would even be attached to direct,
under the prospective title "Superman Lives."
According to Smith, producer Jon Peters
felt that Superman, as a character,
was too queer-coded — which is a nice
way of saying that he kept referring to
the character with homophobic slurs in
his production notes. Because of this
bigoted anxiety, Peters gave Smith three
non-negotiable parameters for his story:
"One: I don't want to see him in that suit.
Two: I don't want to see him fly. And three: He's
got to fight a giant spider in the third act."
Unfortunately, these were far from the last
bizarre notes Smith or Burton would hear during
production, most of which concerned the addition
of scenes and characters that were just there
to sell merchandise. Either because of genuine
quality concerns, the rapidly inflating budget,
or a lack of confidence following the abysmal
response to 1997's "Batman & Robin," "Superman
Lives" was shelved for good in 1998, doomed to
tease fans for 25 years. But now that we have
some part of this promise finally fulfilled,
was it really worth all the hype? Well …
"NO!"
The problem with the lightning-fast "Superman
Lives" sequence is the same problem that follows
the rest of the forced cameos in "The Flash." The
scene plays out with Cage's Superman fighting off
a giant spider, and once he defeats the spider
he just looks directly at the screen. The idea
seems to be that these cameo world's will be
destroyed if the Flash doesn't undo his time
travel actions. But its introduced so last
minute that it never had as much weight as
it should have. Even ignoring the fact that the
CGI model for Cage is far from perfect, the scene
itself is merely slapped onto the outside of
the story with no set-up, payoff, or impact.
If you were looking for a meaningful glimpse
at Tim Burton and Kevin Smith's scrapped
"Superman" project, you're likely gonna be
disappointed. However, for those of us that
go to these multiverse films to feast on as many
Easter eggs as we possibly can, Nicolas Cage's
uncanny turn as Superman makes "The Flash"
every bit the masterpiece it was said to be.